even during a pandemic when fewer of us
are on the road
one unfortunate statistic is still
climbing pedestrian deaths in the valley
they're up 30 percent from last year
today local police are coming together
though to try and promote
crosswalk safety kate houston live at
flamingo in mojave with a look at how to
keep you and your family safe
kate police say that flamingo road is
one of the most dangerous streets for
pedestrians
behind me here you can see there is a
marked crosswalk it even has some
flashing
lights and a sign that says pedestrian
crossing
now with that said we still saw many
people drive through it as
officers were trying to cross this
morning as part of the annual turkey
crossing
a metro officer wore a sparkly turkey
costume
as he attempted to cross the street
police say if drivers won't stop for
this
along with the flashing crosswalk lights
how will they stop for a child or
another person
there have been 56 pedestrian deaths
this year that's
six more lives than last year at this
time metro police are urging drivers to
be aware of their surroundings
especially on roads like flamingo which
allows drivers to go 45 miles per hour
every single one of those persons have
you know they're somebody's child or
somebody's parent
it's unfortunate drivers just slow down
you know it's not worth
getting there 10 seconds early or even a
couple minutes early
metro police say 80 percent of
pedestrian deaths happened between dusk
and dawn walkers are encouraged to wear
bright clothes or
reflective bands on their clothing
police say pedestrians should make eye
contact with drivers before entering a
crosswalk
and clear each lane before moving
forward
today police gave out 123 citations
to drivers who did not stop during the
safety event
one person was arrested for driving
under the influence
reporting from flamingo mojave kate
houston 8 news now